*hip hop music* -The perfect onscreen kiss and how to do it  -Whoah
I've had bad bad kissers the didn't really know the rules.
So we're asking about how to do an onscreen kiss. And how to do it right.
-Yeah, you wanna know the tricks? -Yes -Alright, no eye contact
You have to relax
Not too much tongue.
All tongue. No lips.
You have to pretend that it's someone you really want to make out with.
So you're kind of just like, I call it the fish. It's like...That looked terrible.
You know how it works...I try to open my mouth as wide as I can and try to swallow their whole face.
Don't swallow the other person's face.
Mostly lips with some imagined tongue involved.
But not so much tongue.
But most people don't do the tongue. So, I think you're no supposed to but I'm learning that.
I'm all for a little bit of tongue. Why not?
Usually I just eat a lot of garlic or onions before the kiss.
There's a difference between actual kissing and on screen kissing. You have to make it a little less pornographic.
So don't make it look real.
Grab his face and like, lick it. I'm sure that looked really beautiful
It's better if you like them, for sure, it's way better.
You just gotta go for it.
It's pretty much that easy.
*Hip hop music*
-Why do you think more people don't use tongue? -Uh, maybe for health reasons? Sanitary conditions? Yeah, that guy likes tongue.